hey everyone i'm nate from hugging face
and today we're going to fine tune a
vision transformer for image
classification using hugging pics a
project we put together to make it super
easy to train a vision transformer for
anything using pictures on the web
basically all you have to do is define
the classes you'd like to build an image
classifier for and then we'll use an
image search api to collect images of
those desired classes after that we'll
train a vision transformer on the images
we collect and push it up to the hug and
face hub so anyone around the world can
try out your creation
to get started you can go to the hug and
picks repo on github and click open in
collab to access the demo as a
preliminary step we'll install the
required dependencies once that's
complete we're free to define our search
terms aka the classes that we want to
fine-tune our model to predict
let's say we want to make a dog breed
classifier we simply write the names of
the different dog breeds in the text
boxes and run the cell to lock in our
choices
now we'll run the next couple cells to
download images of those dogs once it
finishes we'll prepare our training and
validation data sets as pi torch data
sets and visualize some examples of the
images we downloaded to see how they
look since the image search api isn't
perfect at this point you may need to go
back and tweak your search terms and
repeat the cells above until the images
look good
but these look good to me so we'll move
forward the next step is to prepare the
label mapping for the model config by
adding label to id and id to label
mapping to our models config we'll get
friendlier labels in the hog and face
inference api
next we'll define a custom collater
class that will prepare examples into
batches that can be unpacked into our
model
great now let's initialize the vit
feature extractor the pre-trained model
the collater and prepare our pi torch
data loaders for the training and
validation sets
to fine tuning itself we're going to use
pytorch lightning and here we see a
simple classifier using lightning that
defines the training step the validation
step and the training optimizer in this
case we're going to use atom with no
learning rate scheduler
okay we're good to train i should only
take a minute or two so just we'll wait
for that
once that's done it's the moment of
truth let's see if it worked so here we
see the predicted labels versus the
actual labels and this looks good enough
for me finally we can share this
fine-tuned model on the hug and face hub
you'll need a hug and face account so if
you haven't already you can go sign up
for free
to authenticate you'll need an access
token with write access so if you don't
have one just add a new one you can name
it whatever you want but make sure to
specify that has right access because
we're going to be pushing up to the hub
we can copy that token and paste it back
in the notebook to authenticate
now we just give it a minute to upload
and once it's finished we can see this
beautiful hug and face model repo is
created for us and we can even drag and
drop the images from the model card into
the inference widget to see an example
prediction
so that's hugging picks the easiest way
to train a vision transformer for
anything using pictures on the web
if you haven't already give it a try
it's super easy use and you don't even
have to write any code if you found this
video helpful why don't you just nudge
up against that like button or if you're
feeling adventurous maybe even make
friends with the subscribe button if
you're looking for more friends than
just the subscribe button though you can
join our discord server to connect with
over 2000 other folks interested in
machine learning that's all for today
thanks for watching and until next time
bye